520 مليون دولار هي قيمه التصفيه التي
ستدفعها اكبر شركات الالعاب العالميه ابيك
قيمز بيانو نظراته لجنه التجاره الامريكيه
اف تي سي تفرض فيه اكبر غرامه في قضيه
المتعلقه بالالعاب وسبب انتهاء قانون
حمايه خصوصيه الاطفال على الانترنت ايبك
قيمز وافقت على دفع الغرامه وقالت انها
تضع حمايه المستهلك على راس اولوياتها
وتسعى لتقديم افضل تجربه للاعبيها
المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه القضيه من
امريكا سليمان
[موسيقى]
الاربعاء حوالي سته مليارات دولار عدد
اللاعبين المسجلين حوالي 400 مليون لاعب
الغرامه 500 وعشرون مليون دولار ارقام
الفلكيا نعم ولكن نعم كلها تتعلق باللعبه
الاكثر شهره على الاطلاق فورتنايت
[موسيقى]
ابك جيمز الشركه المصنعه للعبه الفيديو
الناجحه ستدفع 275 مليون دولار لحكومه
الولايات المتحده لحل المطالبات التي
تنتهي القانون حمايه خصوصيه الاطفال على
الانترنت من خلال جمع المعلومات الشخصيه
للاطفال دون سن 13 عاما دون الحصول اولا
على موافقه الوالدين
كما ستدفع ابيك مبلغ
245 مليون دولار كمبالغ مسترده للمستهلكين
الذي نتضرروا من خيارات التصميم ما مجموعه
520 مليون دولار اكبر غرامه تفرضها لجنه
التجاره الفدراليه على الاطلاق
الشكوى المقدمه ضد فورتنايت تناولت
ادعاءات مثل جمع بيانات الاطفال بطريقه
غير قانونيه وتعريض الاطفال للتنمر
والتحرش واسهلت للاطفال شراء العناصر داخل
اللعبه بنقره واحده او الضغط على زر دون
موافقه الوالدين ما ادى الى تقديم اكثر من
مليون شكوى من الاهالي الى ابيك بشان رسوم
غير المرغوب فيها
والذي يستمر 20 عاما سيحضر على الشركه
استخدامه انماطم مظلمه من على المستخدمين
دون موافقتهم كما طرحت الشركه اصدارا
محدودا لفورتنايت اللاعبين الاصغر سنا
يسمح لهم بالدخول الى بعض الميزات
الانتظار الموافقه الوالدين ولكن هذا يقيد
الدردشه والمشتريات لصباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
6.27 مليار دولار هي عائدات ابك جيمز
المتوقعه مع نهايه عام 2022 واليكم مزيدا
من الارقام 30 مليون مستخدم يمارسون فورت
نايت يوميا وهي لعبه الشركه الاشهر
والمسؤوله عن معظم الارادات 840 مليون
دولار وما انفقه المستخدمون في متجر ايبك
قيمز خلال عام 2001 و 20
مليار دولار هو اجمالي لمستثمارات
32 مليار دولار هي القيمه السوقيه لشركه
ip 2020
في قسم الاقتصادي يسعد صباحك سمر يعني
تحدث عن 520 مليون دولار يعني يعني رقم
كبير ما حجم المبيعات ايه ما حجم المبيعات
التي تحصل عليها شركات الالعاب حتى تفرض
عليها هكذا
هي المصنعه فورت نايت
لانه اول شيء كانت فورتنايت يتم ااه اخذ
بيانات من الاطفال اللي تحت عمر 13 بدون
موافقه اهليتهم همم اخذ هذه البيانات
العمر
البلد اللي ساكنين فيه
التفضيلات هاي اول شيء كانت تقريبا نصف
الغرام راحت على هذا الموضوع ان النص
الثاني من الغرام ما هي ريفاند او تعويض
للاهالي هيرجعوا لهم اهلهم الفلوس الاهل
الاولاد الذين يلعبون لعبه الفورت نايت
اللي همم يتشرجون على الكريدت كارد انت بس
تحطين الكريدت كارد هذا ولد صغير يعني
خصوصا لاقل من 13 انا ابني واحد منهم
بالنهايه يشتري هي صح اللعبه فور فري بس
هي يقال عليها تكاليف مبطنه يعني يبيعوك
مثلا سيف للعبه يبيعوك بلوزه حقيبه تجمع
دولار دولارين دولار دولارين بعدين صدفه
تفاجئت انا قبل تقريبا اسبوعين حتى كانوا
قاعدين يعني فكرنا صار في شيء على الكريدت
كارد انه كل ال- انا كل شهر ينسحب مني
مبلغ معين من ال همم من همم الاله اللي
يستخدمها للالعاب بدون ذكر همم
يعني واحده من الاشياء اللي صارت انه انا
ما اعرف ليش ما اعرف مين بس اعرف الجهه
انه يعني ابني ظاهر هو عنده الكريدت قاعد
على الهايو مشتركه
كارد نفسها حتى ما اتشارج لانه ما اعرف
هذه الطريقه
التي تتبعها هكذا شركات الالعاب لسحب ام
سحب عوائد مثلا بالظبط هو مثل ما قلنا قبل
شويه انه العوائد تقريبا هتتجاوز السته
مليارات دولار هذا العام بالنسبه للشركه
المصنعه لابيك جيمز في الثانيه كمان
روبلوكس اكيد سامعين فيها اكثر تقريبا هذه
وصل مليارين دولار حتوصل منها
اولادنا على الدولار ودولارين وخمس
دولارات فمثلا هذه اليوم منظمه التجاره في
الدلاليه اف تي سي عشان حمله على هؤلاء
الشركات
لتوقيف هذا الموضوع تسمى هذه الحمله دارك
فاتنز او الانماط المظلمه اللي هي تشمل
همم
اول شيء اللي هو الاعلانات المبطنه اللي
انت مثلا هسه نحن مثلا بالعربيه ما مسموح
لنا نبين البراند شو هي لما مسموح لك تبين
عليها
بس انت
بالنهايه ع التلفزيون راح ترون الاشخاص
البرانزلي تستعمليها فهذه ممنوع الدعايات
المبطنه كان الشيء مشاركه البيانات هناك
العديد من الشركات تم تغريدها خصوصا شركات
همم اديوكيشن اون لاين او التعلم عبر
الانترنت اللي صارت وقت الكرونه في اشخاص
حتى اليوم يدفعون اشتراكات ما يعرفون بها
هي من وراء الاشتراكات عبر الانترنت همم
مال شركات التعليمي هذه خصوصا من الشركات
اللي هي تسمى همم صعوبه الالغاء اللي هو
تحت بنت جعل من الصعب الغاء الاشتراكات او
الرسوم مثلا عندك شركه اي بي سي ماوس
مؤخرا ت همم
غرامه بعشره ملايين دولار عندك ايضا في
شيء اسمه دفن المصطلحات والرسوم غير
المرغوب فيها انا نزلت اب قبل يومين فاول
شيء دفعت ان تقريبا 30 دولار العاب خلاص
خلصنا دفعت على العاب المفروض تمام اخذ
عكسس بعدين على كل شيء داخل الاب اشياء
بسيطه كل شيء يتشرجون عليه بعد عندك مثلا
امم مثلا اشتركت معه ايضا اديوكيشن اون
لاين كل سته شهور انا انسى بعد ست شهور
اجي اكنسل هم كل سته شهور يتشرجوني مبلغ
كبير تقريبا 600 درهم همم كل سته اشهر
وانا ما حاسه فيه لانه انسى الغي فهاي
الاشياء اليوم اللي يتم محاربتها والغائها
انه لا يتم التجديد تلقائيا ايضا عندك
ختائل مستحيل لمشاركه البيانات سواء
الاطفال او احنا مش قد ياخذون من عندنا
معلومات انا ابها ذاك المره تطبيق ايضا ست
ناس انت شو عليك ديني شو راح يفرق عندك
انا شو بديني يعني او في حي طرف ثالث انا
شفرق على الفتنه على الرياضه وخساره الوزن
انا وين قاعده صح يعني فهي كلها معلوماتي
يتم بيعها هذه اطراف ثالث طبعا
المعلومات شكرا